巫女は弱視と全問ポーズ
主に視覚障害者が周知することが義務付けられているせいです
また日本の法律では悪場は
視覚障害以外の障害をもつ人が持つことも認めていて
さらに厳密に言うとこのかすぎると思うんですけど
色も白に限らず黄色の杖を持つことも義務づけられた義務付け許されています
ちなみに私は昨日家を持っている人には出会ったことはありません
私は視覚と聴覚に障害を持っているんですが両方とも
程度がとても曖昧です
視覚障害は右目が光を感じる程度で左目は弱視で視野がほとんどありません
今こうやって話しているんですけれども皆さん
がどこにいるのかよく分からないので目が宙を泳いでいたらすみません
そして聴覚障害の方は
左耳が全く聞こえなくて右耳は平均より少し
程度がひっぱ聴力が低いぐらいです
これらの障害によって日常生活で不便さを感じることはとっても多いんですが
この中途半端者が私の学校生活や武器には市場た悪く
酒のことでさえ様々なこんなをもたらすんです
しかし日本社会では薄情=
もー仁全盲の人の杖冬認識が非常に強く
私のような要は中途半端な人が悪女を持って歩いていると
時々
あの人も見えてんじゃないよ
という声が聞こえてきます
またウキウキ私が出会った人とかに自分の見え方について話そうとすると
まあよく言われるのが大丈夫私も老眼だから
とかいや私も眼鏡かけないとよく見えなくてさーと言われてしまって私の話を聞こうと
もせずに
まあ大したことないというふうに片付けられてしまいます
薄情=前号の人の杖という先入観
まあ固定観念によって思考が停止してしまい
まあ
私のことについて私の障害だけじゃなくて私の私という人について知ろうとすること
あるいは障害について理解しようとすることをやめてしまうんです
またある時私は成田空港で飛行機に乗るために手荷物検査を受けていました
すると手荷物検査で荷物をスキャンするところのに買っている係員のお兄さんが
私の白杖を見て硬直してしまいました
彼は私に話しかけることはせず
まあ私と同じ t シャツを着ていた
私と同じ学生団体のほかの学生に
介助者の方ですかご質問されました
私が助けてと言った時以外は健常者と同じように接していた
その学生団体の仲間達はただ
同行者ですと言っただけで何もしませんでした
すると語り員の男性は
まあ俺どうしたらいいのみたいな感じで
当惑してしまいました
このままが手荷物検査を受けられない=団体が飛行機に乗るがが遅れてしまうので私は
あの私は弱視なのでだいたいのことは自分でできるし自分で動けます御質問だったら
直接私におっしゃってください
税をスキャンしていただいて結構です
灯れると
彼はとっても驚いた様子でした
一方アメリカのワシントン dc から成田空港に帰国する際の飛行機に乗るときの手
荷物検査では係員の女性は
まず私に
あなたの杖をスキャンしたいんですがボディー着のところまでご自分でいけますか
それとも私が手を引きましょうか
を問いかけてくださいました
この違いがお分かりになりますでしょうか
日本人は障害者を見るとまず構えてしまいます
そして本人に直接コミュニケーションをとろうとするのではなく
周囲の人に会社の助言を求めようとします
私と成田空港の係員の男性が接する時間というのはほんのわずかなものです
しかし彼は私と直接話をしようとはせず
よは私をしようとすることはせず
他社に助けを求めようとしましたん
この姿勢を私はコミュニケーション不足であると考えます
一方アメリカ人は
薄情持っているかどうかにかかわらず障害を持っている人に出会って
まあ話をしようとすると
まず
何ができて何ができないのかどんな助けが必要なのか本人に直接質問します
その手荷物検査の係の女性は私と直接コミュニケーションをとって私と私を知ろうとし
てくれました
この姿勢を私は今の日本社会にかけている
コミュニケーションの理想のかざし形であると考えています
この日本人とアメリカ人の姿勢の違いは
参加した日米学生会議の参加学生にも顕著に表れていました
日本人の学生の中には
薄情の意味も坐久志とはどういうものなのかも知らない学生もを食いました
中には
まぁめんどくさいことに巻き込まれたくなかったのかもしれないんですけど私と
なるべく関わりを持たないようにする学生さえました
一方でアメリカ人の学生は私が最初にアメリカについて薄情乗って姿を見て以来
朝ごはんとかその他もろもろ顔を合わせるたびに
自ら名乗ってくれて
それに時に話す時間があったときには
リーダーはどういう風な見え方なのどういうふうに話しかけたらわかりやすい
私に積極的にたくさん質問してくれました
彼らは私を理解しようとして私が弱視であると認識した上で接してくれました
日本人の中にも知ろうという姿勢を持ってくれる人
コミュニケーションを図ろうとしてくれる人は少しはいます
大学2年生の時私は日本人にしては珍しいなぁと感じるような男子学生に出会いました
私がある日すぐそこの11号館のまあいわゆる
入口なんですけどいわゆる11ピローアルっていると
突然ある男子学生が私の白杖を見てこれは何だか話しかけてきました
私はちょっとびっくりしたんですがこれはこういうつ上なんだよと説明をしました
すると彼は
じゃああなたはどんな資格証がお持ちなんですかお皿に質問してきました
彼と面識がなく全くなくって誰どこの誰かも分からない私は何なんだこの人だと思った
んですが
まあ私はこういう見え方なんですと説明をしました
すると彼は納得してお時間取れずですいませんでしたと言って去っていきました
まあ突然面識もないのに突然話しかけてきて
スクだけのことを聞いて
part 去っていってしまった彼は一見非常識かもしれません
ですが私は
冒頭にお話ししたように陰でコソコソ話されるよりも
彼のように直接聞いてくれた方がまだ気持ちが良かったんです
なぜなら彼は
自分の無知さをさらけ出してでも
自分が失礼な人だと思われてでも障害者についてあるいはこの薄情の意味について
知ろうとして理解しようとする姿勢を私に見せてくれたからです
障害者の中には自分の生涯についてあまり人に知られたくないという人もいるのが事実
です
知ろうとしない健常者と伝えようとしない障害者
それで困ったことが何もないだろう
構わないと思います
しかし障害者というのは健常者と比べてすべてにおいて困難が多いから障害者なんです
自分の生涯について使えないのは彼らの自由かも知れませんだからあえてここで私が
買われるということもできないのかもしれません
しかしそのような聞かれたくないという障害者の存在によって
健常者は障害のことについては私が踏み込んではいけない領域なんだ聞いちゃいけない
んだ
認識してしまって
一方で私のようにまた他の知ってもらいたいと思っている人のように
障害についてある程度理解して接してもらわなければ
困ってしまう障害者はどんどん行きにくくなってしまいます
もし皆さんが
白杖を持った人に出会ったり
まあ他の障害を持った一人であってその障害に対して疑問を持って
別に大したことないんじゃないのとか
見えてるじゃんとかそんな風に今に思ったときは
陰でコソコソ話すぐらいだったら直接
問いかけてみてほしいなと私は考えます
そして今ここにいらっしゃるかわかりませんが
障害者障害を持った人は
自分の生涯についてぱ者にも知ってもらう勇気を持ってみてはどうでしょうか
人は伝え合わなければ理解し合うことができません
それはコミュニケーションの
まあテクノロジーが発達してコミュニケーションの対応しかして
直接顔を合わせなくても連絡が取れるようになった今なお更重視されることだと私は
思います
知ろうとする姿勢等
伝えようとする発信しようとする勇気
この2つの
2つがの姿勢が生み出すコミュニケーションの充実によって
障害者と健常者がよりよく共存する未来に繋がると私は信じていますね木部町